[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whether
intentional or not i know that in a lot
of the top 10 lists on this channel
the shows that get featured are often
the shonen titles now i honestly don't
think that's a bad thing but every once
in a while it makes me think of spicing
things up a little bit hey
variety creates excitement so for
today's top 10 list
we'll be skipping over one piece naruto
and all the shows like that for today
we'll be taking a look at 10 of the more
mature titles that you can enjoy
these shows are much darker and deal
with more serious themes
but are still as action-packed as it
gets if you need to convince your friend
to get into the medium through some dark
and mature shows
allow me to help you out
to begin our list we have chinese
electric batman show
darker than black sporting a much more
noir aesthetic darker than black is one
of my picks among the late 2000s action
anime
it features a city cloaked in darkness
where gates have emerged
drastically altering the landscape
contractors emerged these are people who
exchanged humanity and conscience for
powers their lack of aversion to killing
makes them perfect spies for the power
struggle among countries in the world
one such contractor is our protagonist
hey
the black reaper as he's called
undertakes missions for the syndicate
while searching for the truth as to what
happened to his sister along the way the
truth about the contractors starts
unraveling in this high octane thriller
a sci-fi thriller that's littered with
political themes and questionable
morality
darker than black is one of the gems of
its decade i think it really deserves
more love so i'm recommending it to you
if you want some dark
action show to spend your days with now
doesn't darker than black's world look
just a little bit familiar of course it
does we're currently living in a world
becoming more and more integrated with
technology
and who knows we could be at the cusp of
a sci-fi world mirroring the one we see
in darker than black so for that reason
we have to make adjustments to the
ever-changing world and start investing
in cyber security
hence we have the sponsors of this video
dashlane
dashlane is your ever trustworthy buddy
in cyberspace
it's a cross-platform application that
helps you manage your personal info and
doubles as a digital wallet making
online checkouts a breeze
the app allows you to autofill your
personal info like addresses and
passwords
and it can even generate strong
passwords for you as well given the
world's ongoing shift to digital pretty
much everything and now it's easy to
lose track of things
that does sound like a pretty good deal
now doesn't it dashlane also has
a vpn so you don't have to worry about
those pesky trackers when you browse the
internet plus you can access
different kinds of content wherever you
are so try dashlane on your first device
for free
by heading to
vinnie www.dashlane.com and when you
want to upgrade to premium the first 100
people
get 25 percent off with the code vinnie
tube
[Music]
coming in at number nine we look at the
cute and innocent madoka magicka
colourful backgrounds cute characters a
lovable mascot character so you're
telling me this
is a saiyan title first impressions can
lie and innocent watches are in for a
nasty surprise a couple of episodes in
ready your mind and your tissues the
premise is simple enough
a cat-like creature called cube a goes
around granting wishes in exchange for a
girl becoming a magical girl a magical
girl then gets to fight witches
monsters that while grotesque in
appearance don't exactly constitute mind
[ __ ] material
at first anyway along the way more
mysteries about the magical girl system
get unravelled
and it seems that kyubey is more than
what you think he is oh and that homura
character
hers is a long story best experienced so
go ahead and check out the series or the
compilation movies to get started on the
franchise madoka magika is arguably one
of the most influential anime in the
past decade hey i would even go as far
as to say that it started the whole
dark magical girl show trend the
industry went through it's not the first
magical girl anime that has dark and
serious themes by a long shot
but it's the first one that mattered
enough to start a whole revolution
to the point that it's harder to find a
straight up by the book classic magic
girl show than a trigger happy violent
one these days
[Music]
for those who were around during the
late 2000s helsing would probably be the
edgy recommendation of choice for most
fans i'd say that such a reputation is
to be deserved
as this story of badass vampire alucard
is one of the more gripping dark
fantasies out there at the time on one
hand it seems to be a typical vampire
story
but boy does helsing make a spectacle
out of it in terms of action i still
think the helsing ultimate holds up to
the titans of today
helsing ultimate doesn't pull its
punches it has
violence tension swearing gore
edgy characters and darkness everything
that an edgy teen
who lives and breathes the deviant
subculture in its era could have dreamed
of however underneath all those lies a
story that remains exciting all
throughout
littered with cool moments that never
cease to get your heart racing it would
be easy to brand helsing ultimate as a
dumb fun series and while i'd agree to a
certain extent which is why the show
doesn't go any higher than eighth the
over-the-top way it plays to its
strengths just
can't be overlooked
[Music]
a world where technology has become
integrated with humanity seems a
far-fetched possibility decades ago but
with the recent developments in real
life it seems more and more likely
the idea of a society like that starts
becoming more and more interesting
despite its level of appeal varying
depending on who you ask
what are the implications of such a
world the ghost in the shell series
looks to answer those questions
in a world where cybernetic enhancements
have become the norm major madoka
kusanagi leads her anti-cyber crime team
on the hunt for an entity known as
puppet master a fierce foe who's
mastered the art of hacking brains and
implanting false memories
in order to turn innocence into a life
of crime ghost in the shell is one of
the most beloved series that deals with
the cyberpunk premise and for good
reason you get treated to a good dose of
content on psychology and the series
themes that we philosophy and technology
has more or less played a big role in
anime gaining popularity worldwide if
you just can't get enough of ghost in
the shell the good news is that more
content is still being made for it in
the present so it's never too late to
hop on the train
psychopaths tells of a world where
people are monitored by the civil system
in this futuristic dystopian society
people are monitored according to
arbitrary scores that tolerate to their
tendency to do crime sounds like a dream
world for law enforcement but
a scary prospect for civilians i find it
interesting that psychopaths is becoming
more and more socially relevant with
each passing day the story at first
glance revolves around the public safety
bureau and their days of fighting crime
however for me the more important
underlying theme
in psychopaths is the question of
whether something like the civil system
is worth the price of freedom and the
civilians right to weave their fates
that's not to say that psychopaths is
all thought and introspection
in addition to its social commentaries
it also has some really great action
sequences
a couple which made it to my previous
videos on top anime fights combining a
very
socially relevant theme with action cool
art and awesome character design
is a surefire way to success and the
success of the franchise
illustrates just that
[Music]
for most people the name berserk would
probably trigger some ptsd from the meme
worthy 2016 adaptation
however back in 1997 there was actually
a decently animated berserk tv series
yep it was the two-core berserk
adaptation that adapts the black
swordsman arc all the way to the golden
age storylines
a couple of you fans are already
familiar with guts and this anime mostly
tells of his story as he joins the band
of the hawk
led by the charismatic griffith in their
journey the powerful guts climbs the
ranks as he learns more about the grim
truth of the world
it also ends with a wham a
world-changing event
but i won't spoil it here i'll let you
watch the series to find out for
yourself a series that relishes on
violence and the dark fantasy narrative
berserk 97 was met with tremendous
acclaim
even though it's not exactly a perfect
adaptation of the masterpiece that is
the manga that's why it
does drop a few places for me i'd also
recommend you watch the third berserk
movie after you finish this one the
series was dark
it was jaded and it was brutal just the
way the fans love it however it also
tells of an epic that stands the test of
time
[Music]
before durarana was a thing there was
this series called
baccano taking place in america's
prohibition era
baccano has it all thieves gangsters
mafia wars immortality elixirs and all
those elements of classic pulp fiction
with 13 episodes vacano has an
astounding 12 main characters and while
it can cause some problems in developing
each of them
i think that the dynamics shown between
each pair of characters makes for a
really enjoyable watch there's little
down time embarcano and the series makes
full use of its limited episodes in
piecing together its intriguing plot
barca note takes the unique approach
that we can see shades of it in its
successor durarara
specifically the non-linear storytelling
it puts together drama
action and comedy in an arguably short
story but it's one that's very engaging
the characters remain the strongest suit
of this show and if you're up for a show
with some amazing dynamics playing out
in a short but sweet plot
bakano could be the show for you
[Music]
talk about an old eba goodie parasite is
the adaptation of an 80s manga under the
same name in a nutshell it talks about a
world invaded by aliens that latched
themselves into people and turned them
into vicious killers of men
however not all people who were unlucky
enough to be chosen as a host
end up being a puppet of the aliens
thanks to his earphones
shinichi manages to stop the possession
from an alien and contain it within his
right hand
getting a will and a life of its own his
right hand gets christened as
migi now a being that's both man and
parasite shinichi and migi must work
together in order to survive the other
parasites out for blood the two beings
that share a body but retain their
individual intellect start to form a
bond as they quickly become the target
of aliens hell bent on devouring human
society
parasite has a lot of cool action
sequences and i find it's most notable
for its dubstep soundtrack that gives it
some uniqueness it also shows its age
with its heavily environmentalist theme
since we don't see that in much manga
nowadays
but i think that those themes are all
the more relevant in this day and age
who hasn't heard of the newest title on
the list i'm sure that if you guys have
been watching anime for the past half
year or so you would have definitely
heard of this title and deservingly so
villain saga is for me a serious
candidate if not the winner
for anime of the decade it tells the
tale of torfin
son of the mighty tours and his quest
for revenge after his father's death
instead of being a violent revenge story
you'd expect from the premise
finland saga is more than that it's a
graphic story about the realities of war
sprinkled with historical angles that
help you appreciate the era
besides being an immersive tale of
vikings in their relationship with
exploration and war
villain saga also explores a lot of grim
realities of life during those ages
it also features some of the best
character dynamics i've ever seen in
recent anime
as well as some of the best fights in
terms of building tension and
capitalizing on it
a gritty story that doubles as an
educational foray into the harsh truths
of war and morality
vinland saga is a show that no one
should miss
[Music]
cemeteries
another candidate for anime of the
decade this urobucha masterpiece
chronicles the holy grail war that takes
place before the one we're familiar with
not only does this dark action series
tell the much awaited story of kiritsugu
it also gives us a glimpse of saver and
gilgamesh before their appearances in
the fate stay
night proper being a work done by gen
urobuchi who's also responsible for
madoka magicka and psychopaths by the
way
expect a lot of themes around grey
morality a high body count
and a wild ride that ends with a finale
that's bittersweet at best however such
dark themes alone won't make a series so
good so i've also got to hand it to the
anime team who produce some of the most
magnificent animation and soundtrack
choices for a show of this calibre
that and the voice acting really made
this series come alive
and for a grand story of this caliber
i'd expect nothing less
fate zero is overall a really great
roller coaster of emotions
that not only helps establish the fan
favorite fate stay night series but also
opened anime up to a lot of people
interested in action
historical figures and a gripping story
so what do you think maybe now you've
got something to show your friend who
wants to get into anime perhaps with
these shows you can help demonstrate how
anime is so varied and that not
everything comes down to cute girls
doing cute things
or friendships and bonds and saving the
day if there are any other anime that
you want to suggest
make sure to leave them down in the
comment section below if you also
enjoyed the slight change in content
make it known by liking the video and
we'll see if we can do a volume 2
of this list don't forget to check out
our sponsors of this video
dashlane the links in the description
for now that's got to do it
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you